This staircase is steeper,
it will be much more difficult
to climb this staircase.
We're actually seeing here when you see
a staircase with a greater steepness
than this one is a staircase
with a larger slope.
But we're mathematicians, it's not
enough to know that this one is steeper
than this one,
we want to know by how much.
We want to put a number to
this thing we call a slope.
The definition of slope is
that it's the vertical change
divided by the horizontal change.
Or a good way to remember this is that
it's the rise divided by the run,
and we'll talk a little
bit about what this means.
For example, let's look at this
set of stairs, and let's say that
they have a vertical change,
the height we could say of 5 feet.
They also have a horizontal
change which is also 5 feet.
This staircase, on the other hand,
has a vertical change of 10 feet but
also has a horizontal change of 5.
If I want to calculate
the slope of this staircase,
I would take the vertical change,
the rise of 5 feet and
divide it by the run, also 5 feet and
5 divided by 5 is equal to 1.
Likewise for this staircase,
if I want to calculate the slope,
I'd use 10 feet as the rise because
that's how tall the staircase is and
I divide it by this horizontal run of 5.
And 10 divided by 5 is equal to 2.
This is the slope of 1, and
this is the slope of 2.
Just like we said, intuitively,
if this staircase is steeper,
our slope calculation is the same
thing because 2 is bigger than 1.